il m'a promis qu'il allait pour vous
pour le public nous refaire bécassine
comme devrait se situer près oui alors
oui il n'ya pas de quoi il n'y a pas de
[ __ ] alors il a partout sur ce piano
j'ai cru tout une rafle tout à l'heure
non mais j'ai parlé de colin de les
donner quand on aime tout commencé la
journée avec une bonne baguette non
plus hier
cécile s'il ya bien un politique qui lui
plaît c'est le patron du sénat
larcher s'est dit là il aurait ma
préférence si il se présentait je
voterai pour le riz moi je les écoute
moi cet homme-là salon quel mur fallait
la tête sur les épaules et qui ne
montrent pas que le reste mais trois
quarts des temps et nous montrent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un
tel manque pas
mais sincèrement
ça fait deux heures que je suis là je
suis chauffeur de taxi comment je vais
faire calmez vous madame personne
d'entre vous dis villecien 75 7 me soit
mieux au moins on n'avait pas un bon je
dis on n'a plus rien plus d'essence plus
dense plus de literie
j'aurai terminé d'aller en enfer on est
tous déjà tu as été absolument
exceptionnel où la clé ses premières
tournées elle soit la porte j'ai ouvert
la porte avec à huy donc aller perdu
mais n'ont même pas tout ça pour ça a
cessé jouvert network rien il fallait
trois mots clés
donc on essaie de rester quatre à cinq
respiration à chaque fois way we cette
petite bosse là elle me dérange
ma vie comme enjeu falloir se
débrouiller avancer un peu vos mains
allez-y avancer vraiment je vous
autorise voilà tape épique et maintenant
les faits si rentrer votre tête voilà
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors qu'elle entame son titre culte
skyfall adèle voit au loin fan faire un
malaise au milieu de la foule
[Musique]
la chanteuse va alors guider les secours
depuis la scène pour que le fan en
question soit prise en charge plus
rapidement et marquer quoi et où somme
oui c'est de l'anglais
to b likasi
[Applaudissements]
d'os de tigre
[Musique]
et puis seul l'autre problème c'est que
ces amitiés virtuelles prennent du temps
aussi sur les amitiés réelles journée
une sont pas extensibles donc si je
passe quatre heures par jour sur un
écran le même si c'est pour mes amis
virtuels et bien ces quatre heures je ne
peux pas les consacrer aux créatures
réel qui est vive tout autour de moi si
je réussis toujours à trouver du plaisir
à venir sur ce caillou c'est parce que
en fait j'ai rendez vous avec lui il ya
surtout le fait de faire dans le
sentiment de faire partie d'un groupe et
d'un groupe de de gens merveilleux alors
je m'arrêterai là parce que
c'est cacher parce qu'on peut l'utiliser
sans avoir internet
pareil pour les appareils photos par
internet
pas de vidéo et pas d'eau est fier mais
c'est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'on cherche dans un magasin normal en
fait
c'est moins cher du
maintenant c'est plus cher
c'est plus cher de ne pas avoir internet
oui c'est plus cher de ne pas avoir
internet c'est le futur
c'est icc services on rigole mais si on
rigole pas en suicide tous
surtout quand c'est sa part devant
couper la clim